hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
wäre hallo ich bin aufgewachsen ist hat
auch mit dabei genau und heute gibt ein
schnelles rezept und zwar nie ein
schnelles video es gibt drei rezepte in
einem ich werde nämlich drei leckere
dips machen die ihr zum beispiel beim
grillen zubereiten könnt und daneben das
servieren könnt ich würde immer ganz oft
von meinen zuschauer nach diesen tipps
gefragt denn ich mache die auch immer
ganz gerne auf messen
wenn wir unterwegs sind und ihr könnt
ihr wirklich super schnell zubereiten
könnte dann im kühlschrank lagern
entweder mitnehmen zu einer grill oder
gartenparty oder eben zu hause servieren
und diese tipps vor allem diesen paprika
vätertyp und den tomaten gibt auch schon
fertig zu kaufen die gibt es zum
beispiel auch bei der weise griechischen
und türkischen feinkost oder auch
arabischen oder kanal in feinkostläden
gibt sie eben ganz oft im blut hatte
holen wir sie ab und so wobei man die
eben auch selber nachmachen kann ich
werde zwei drei tipps machen uns weiß es
einmal ein guter tipp 1 paprika philipp
und ein tomaten chili tipp richtig
lecker ich zeige euch mal die zutaten
mit den ersten tipp für die avocado
homole brauche ich eine reife avocado
eine halbe zitrone einen halben
teelöffel salz und eine knoblauchzehe 1
halben esslöffel olivenöl eine tomate
und halten es löffel joghurt für den
zweiten tipp das ist der paprika federt
er brauche ich eine halbe rote paprika
100 g feta-käse 100 gramm frischkäse und
jeweils einen halben teelöffel oregano
und rosmarin und eine knoblauchzehe und
für den dritten weg brauche ich 100
gramm feta-käse 100 gramm fisch käse
einen halben esslöffel olivenöl 50 gramm
getrocknete tomaten eine chance und eine
chili
jetzt mache ich erstmal den ersten blick
das ist die guacamole dafür nämlich
jetzt die avocado und dies übrigens reif
wenn ihr hier oben diesen stil entfernt
und wenn es darin grün ist ist sie reif
und wes brown bis sie nicht reif
als kleiner live so jetzt die avocado
halbieren
sie hatten kern bringen mit den kameras
machen kann es sei ja den kannst du auch
bei smoothies mit mixen
das soll auch sehr gesund sein kern
entfernen
egal ob bei schlossern was nicht das
erinnert an die usa - diese genau aus
wie ich
naja jedenfalls nimmt jetzt das innere
der avocado heraus ob es schlechter wird
nicht dadurch wie ich heute funktioniert
bei jäger heute locken wird sagen läuft
macht uns den trick mit dem glas wein
coolsten das ist ein der mango also bei
dem punkt setzen
mit einem löffel bekommt ihr das hier
bei der avocado sehr gut dann nehme ich
jetzt noch die zitrone und knete sie ein
bisschen da kommt jetzt das auf der
halben zitrone noch mit atom und dann
gebe ich noch salz mit dazu und kann es
dann jetzt drücken entweder mit einer
gabel oder mit seinem kartoffelstampf
die knoblauch sehr eilig noch mit rein
dann kommt auch der joghurt mit dazu und
das olivenöl
jetzt könnte die ganzen pfeffer
abschmecken
nochmal schön zerdrücken dann vermischen
sich alles gut was ist mir noch nicht so
gestampft und moralisch zu verschmerzen
ii zwar keine gabel nehmen was eine
gabel zu begraben
jetzt können wir die kommune entweder so
lassen oder ihr geht noch eine tomate
mit dazu das mache ich nämlich jetzt
dafür die tomate halbieren und das
kernige gehäuse aber entfernen sonst
wird einfach zu wässrig und dann wird
später sich so eine wird sich die
flüssigkeit oben sammeln
tomaten das könnt ihr einfach aufessen
und den rest jetzt fein würfeln
jetzt kommen die tomaten hier noch mit
dazu und dann alles verrührt und der
erste tipp ist dann gleich fertig
jetzt zum zweiten sieg das ist ja der
paprika väter tipp dafür nimmt jetzt die
zutaten die paprika habe ich bereits in
grobe stücke geschnitten
die kommen jetzt in einem mixer und
stabmixer würde auch gehen aber da muss
man die paprika natürlich noch ein
bisschen kleiner schneiden und jetzt
habe ich hier auch wenn feta käse
das sollte jetzt darauf achten dass soll
einer seien mit hohem fettgehalt darf
ich jetzt hier diesen gar siegen und mit
60 prozent fettanteil denn dadurch wird
dieser tipp dann noch mal richtig cremig
also das wirklich gut und den findet man
auch wirklich in allen supermärkten
den gebe ich jetzt in groben stückchen
mit das so dann auch gleich die
knoblauchzehe und die gewürze
jetzt wird es zuerst einmal etwas früher
gefordert der frischkäse dazu kommt und
sobald die zutaten vermischt sind kommt
noch der frischkäse meter dann könnt ihr
das ganze mit salz und pfeffer
nachwürzen
ich gebe immer erst mal bisschen pfeffer
rein und das trauma normalerweise gar
nicht weil er käse schon 20 ist aber
einfach probieren uns selber abschmecken
für den dritten tipp habe ich jetzt hier
bereits die getrockneten tomaten mit
heißem wasser übergossen
nach 17 minuten quellen lassen ihr könnt
aber auch beispielsweise die tomaten in
öl eingelegt nehmen da müsste das
nämlich nicht machen
kommen die ausgedrückt die oben in den
mixer da kommen die schalotten mit rein
und die chili bedarf stieg auch der
schafskäse und das ganze wieder fein
mixen dann noch im dezember rein und
frischkäse und auch das olivenöl nicht
nur noch alles gut
o
die 3 disc ist auch wirklich super
schnell und wie gesagt kann man sie auch
im kühlschrank lagern gut vorbereiten
und dann einfach mitnehmen und der mogat
unser verkäufer darf jetzt natürlich
auch probieren wie haltbar
die sind halt war also die kommune ist
am wenigstens lange haltbar die würde
ich jetzt vielleicht zwei tage maximal
aufheben aber alles andere kann fasst
bis zu einer woche aufheben
genau ich immer gut verschließen genau
gelesen im kühlschrank wenn man nicht
verschließt stinkt halt auch der ganze
kühlschrank nach knoblauch zwiebeln
genau unseren kleinen tipp immer mit
einem frischen luft eigentliche problem
ist also heute gibt es für dich prozent
natürlich sind das grillen von ihr
wirklich zum grillen dazu servieren zu
fleisch oder gemüse oder brot einfach
als wir essen das total gern aufs boot
vor allem bei mir wenig
sonntagsfrühstück dann mache ich mir
super gerne guacamole lege ich richtig
lecker also der dieb april hatte ich
kenne ja schon ein schild wenn man sich
jetzt muss ehrlich sagt ja wenn man den
bisschen schärfer mag so wie ich dann
kann man ruhig noch natürlicher eingeben
aber dieses so schon ja ganz okay
schon von der schärfe somit ist die
schärfe angenehm aber ich würde für mich
persönlich wahrscheinlich noch ein wenig
nicht stellen würde also mit ich auch
super
und wie gesagt ich so eine havarie chili
reingewaschen und die mag ich besonders
mag a mole vor allem wenn sie so bisher
säuerlich erst noch salz und den
knoblauch super lecker und da kann ich
dazu gar gs zeichen also auch ja da
passt alles gute dann aber kam ohne
titel sogar irgendwie verrückt aber ich
bin sogar für fisch benutzen bisschen
augenblick ja ja man kann ja so und man
kann die sie verwenden wofür man möchte
jedenfalls hoffe ich dass ich diese
rezepte gefallen haben und falls es sie
nach machen wollt könnt ihr nochmal
nachlesen auf jolie.de und ich wünsche
euch ganz viel spaß dabei genau oder ihr
langen zu grün ein und bringt die gibbs
mit ja das können wir auch genau laden
zum grillen ein
wir kommen vorbei und bringt die jeeps
mit tipps und brot gelobt das kann ich
auch noch schaffen alles